all right hi I'm gonna show you in this
video how to change the key fob or
excuse me the key battery in a Honda
Civic key from 2014 to present the Civic
uses this this key with the rectangular
buttons so if we flip the key over you
can see there's a little tiny screw
there now what you're gonna need is not
a just a regular screwdriver but a
little precision screwdriver like this
this set here you get this for four
bucks on Amazon I'll link to it below
this video so the first time you take
the screw out it'll be kind of tough
because it's down pretty low and it's
pretty tight so just unscrew this I've
already kind of loosened it so this is
gonna go a lot quicker than it might for
you your first time but you really have
to push down to get this screw out so
once you've gotten that out drop that
out and then on this side here you'll
notice there's a little slot go ahead
and take a flathead screwdriver take
this large flat one from your set and
stick it in the side there and if you
kind of twist it'll start to break apart
and break apart but there's two pieces
to this clamshell fob and you can start
if you just kind of twist you'll be able
to pop off the top of the key here which
was gonna be access to the battery that
we need to change so you can take your
flat-head screwdriver and just pop out
the CR 16 23 volt battery so see that go
ahead there just make sure when you put
another one back in that positive side
is down here and if you if you kind of
put in the top side first like I'm doing
here it'll go in a lot easier okay so
once you've got a new one in go ahead
and just reassemble the fob and put the
two pieces back together a little snap
back together pretty easily and then go
ahead and put your little baby screw
back in and that's it that's how you
change key battery on a Honda Civic Bob
flatten so a little tiny Phillips one
and just screw that back in and you're
all set and again the battery type is a
CR 16 23 volt coin battery